fatti 5 alle mucche quindi allora chissà
come funziona altri sistemi che lo stato
magari ci credito il complottista
ciao ragazzi bentornati una puntata
speciale del guglielmo tell
oggi infatti abbiamo optato per un elmo
hotel del mare un guglielmo tell
interattivo gli ha chiesto di mandare
delle stories su instagram taggando me è
l'ospite di oggi nel quasi propriamente
nelle quali ci proponeva te che cosa
ragazzi non sa perché ciao ragazzi
bentornati a una puntata speciale del
guglielmo perché milano tel
ciao ragazzi bentornati su puntata
speciale del guglielmo tell
finalmente sono riuscito a visitare i
miei congiunti in queste giornate di
fase ii e mi ritrovo in questo momento a
un metro di distanza dall ospite di
questa puntata i tamburi mio fratello
gabriele gabriele fanno vedere in camera
il carico in braccio
abbiamo calcolato una distanza di un
metro detto ciò che cosa ho fatto
gli abbiamo chiesto entrambi di farci
sapere che cosa fare insieme tagliandoci
in alcune stories di instagram quindi
farò adesso è aprire il mio telefono
andare sul profilo e vedere che cosa ci
avete proposto va bene ma io sempre
quello del tg collocato fa bene che
mandiamo avanti 6 8
questo è il primo ma ne scelti tu
cosa fa vivente rainer frimmel di rim in
un'altra cosa
ti correggo guglielmo non abbiamo in su
melania andiamo avanti con il servizio
che bene di vista in sé niente non sono
passato da case vitamine per andare
proprio a prelevare un eyeliner ed è per
questo che ti presento lay line e che
useremo oggi carta allora ecco qua
eyeliner questo sembra un po meno cane e
non potevo dire la cosa sembra il dono
principia ii inizia l'esperto in realtà
io non so mi aspetto che allora alice e
fa questo i boston hanno vinto ho capito
questo di fare poi guardare il piacere
un paragone faccio io non mi tieni e
nello specchio posto scusante un grande
istanza spiacente arrangi locana drogati
il modo per riuscire a fare la challenge
highline ai tipo di apple
l'aj di bocchio lainate vaghe come
cacchio fai tu ti ti ti posi messina
mammamia anche sonno che ci stai facendo
venire ma le pagine guarda sembra che
bambino picchiato un mese fa wow mancato
il coraggio di dire mi sembra di tipo
munain brille rai con le altre donne non
vedranno mai molto valore ci darà
comunque non siamo nella cina feudale
che diventi nessuno destro mancino
questa che cos'è la destra non c'è dato
molto onore perché al proprio padre mi
arrendo conseguito questo quella mia
nonna da fare a tebe io vorrei dire che
non l'ho mai messo ma al contrario
invece ogni sera guarda io così diceva
ad andarmene molto noi chi ha rai cioè
smd parte da solo l'operazione del
cranio io ho sbagliato io dovevo fare
questo invece ho fatto la destra e poi
devo fà un buffetto finale no se vuoi
sistena non hai scritto no no no no deve
fare abbiamo sbagliato ma da cui partì
da quel dentro pagina delle sopracciglia
fatto vedere ma non è abbastanza
aggiungerà diversamente
che abbiamo il critico vai un po di
aletta tanto per non far sentire che mio
padre da solo per me lo faccio priest è
molto più bravo di me sono stato molto
più veloce di te che l'ha portata qui
sul web
ragazzi non riescono a un rom che resta
è andato a fare bene che ha vinto a
questa è la quale dice devi ribaltare
sto cercando di vedere almeno poi ti
dico come fai tu vabbè se quello
atletico sono questioni di scheda comuni
che io poi ho 75 kg al massimo e scena
mia meglio infatti mi preoccupavo per me
non per te facciamola autorizzandolo
iniziamo da ecc
la presa non essere qui deve essere qui
bravo così ritroviamo la famosa cena
veloce per lo scalfo carollo di
passaggio 1 massaggio 2
[Applauso]
si no
[Musica]
e lei fatte le pieghe come fai schifo
perché questi tipi della lingua marina
sa fare eccolo viene qui la vita l'ha
fatto la linea degli esami oggi appunto
da prendere che sta facendo bene
stavo guardando majanese baby quelle
linee unilever che indossa milioni nei
vari libri proiezioni di vestiti con i
miei si possa fare
non l'ho mai provato ma penso proprio
che si fa in quella mente devi fare
prima la verticale poi poggi una gamba e
con la tecnica dell'opposizione per il
brunch in equilibrio ok dovremmo provare
adesso l'ho detto con nuove ragazze
addio
io l'ho visto principali bravo benissimo
sta malissimo già fatto
ma che volete provare delle libere
scusate consiste mettere completo e
questo risultato ma non ha senso questo
video io ad aggirarla i 330 faccia una
posizione sessuale tutta la riviera in
faccia non ho paura fa attenzione al mio
telefono mai infilano farci attenzione
nel 28 lega intimato a lei messale fatto
la testa dentro me la faccio gira a
bocca al lupo 321 e funziona cioè
giustamente a distruggerla bellissimo
guardare i vari si mostra bravissimo
[Musica]
se consumato quell'altra quella di
pollici ma io con le peggiori secondi se
diesel po all'inizio del mio pollice
schifo
1236 resti lassù non fa niente per 23
estensioni spiazza noi avevamo le mani
10 m scusa ma se 2 a 0 lazio al meglio
di tre ma certo bisogno quindi intreccia
entra ha vinto ma deve contare a zero
non è un gioco che mi piace la pressione
di osan compressione se si aggirava
contrario come ti pochi contenuti è nato
qui e poi gira nel braccio o di cha ha
fatto questo ha fatto fare un altro
altri nove mesi sta girando a tornare su
acqua e hanno mourinho intanto volevo
ricordare di comprare il mio libro
elogio del q al libro che stavo cercando
da tanto tempo
l'ho ritrovato come voi leggete lopresto
ti ringrazio e il come lo specchio
dell'anima ognuno il coppia mostra mirko
e ti dirò chi sei
fammi vedere la challenge cup alla prova
in un cie ma è che si intende così ovvio
che non ti ci siamo in campagna si e poi
passa grazie risiede nel grazie
per il leader dei the machine e gli
spezzoni di film completo prendi tu
adoro hanno malattie stare insieme
brava al famosissimo 9 problema è così
tornato ho detto pure che ho detto fra
l'altro detto guglielmo ma no e qui è
morivi ti rivedi il girato guglielmo
cevolin abbandonati proprio da iaia
marino stamattina non è che abbiamo la
stessa ragione e chi finisce prima il
nome lo hai fatto fra anche lui e con la
rai ne vada pronto per il secondo
piccola festa
[Musica]
se non ci sono i primi sospetti
l'attore finita il labirinto della print
labili fair questa e labyrinth queste
labyrinth e che ne so se mi dici questa
è la b l'inter vostro sì qui siamo sotto
canale installabili sotto ci dovete
decretare chi ha vinto perché siamo
ignoranti davanti marcelo veramente
partito non si apre l'asta una storia di
titoli così uno faceva f1 orizzontale
nati nella pagina crescerebbe vedere hip
hop mi facevo io forse ha fatto io
prendevo guardavo tutte le risposte
primi segnato tutto produzione del
tramonto all'alba dal tramonto all'alba
no perché ha detto alba secondo lei dal
tramonto all'alba ma poi negli anni 60
quelli di mokoena cioè il capello da ken
e quello tutto bloccato quasi da
travolta all'altro va beh non lo so film
dove dice alba vediamo che sia ai comuni
la maschera di zorro
non basta dire zone è completo aspetta
che poi no che vai al 10
marone giappone non era neanche la
maschera di zorro sembrava 2001 odissea
nello spazio con zorro high school
musical ha mai visto quindi non lo so io
vorrei fare i complimenti a questa
ragazza perché solamente dato fuori una
super challenge in realtà anche se io
non ok tesoro mi si sono ristretti i
ragazzi ok gli atti non ho poco capiti
nella b1
l'abitino mai visto rai dal tramonto
all'alba vabbè tanto sceglieranno qua
sotto quindi sono tranquillo
questa dopo fisico la coppia che ci deve
venire perfetta a udine a giampaolo
passa sotto minaccia provino le mani di
a terra dai
ma secondo te chi prende in campo a
molto se si sveglia si vede se stesso
solo io ragazzi sono legate alla fine di
questo video io ringrazio gabriele per
essersi fatto stracciare dal
sottoscritto soprattutto se volete anche
voi le sfide che ci avete proposto
insomma tutto quello che abbiamo fatto
oggi fatelo stancandoci su instagram 1
dove potremo riportarvi e vedesse essere
stati più bravi di me o più facilmente
di gabriel il bello di tutto questo è
che mi sta facendo la chiusura ancor
prima di aver fatto le prove quindi lui
ha stabilito che avvisino prosopopea
perché furtive questa pro so come è
andata la parola da visitare i siti a
questo canale metteteci un bel pollice
su per il conte prosopopea però sopra
tea almeno due e scrivete commentato il
prosopopea over ai periodi non sarebbe
piaciuto perché se non lo mettono
commentate con prove
andiamo a farli adesso però succederà